[Music]
like
[Music]
good okay everyone that was good so we
could do 10 better that was beautiful
very very good
how my friends from college are here
perfect timing welcome to the set of
chandar dastani icarus
i'm playing you you like the costume we
need to talk tell the director i have
some notes we need to talk to you in
private
oh karon he's worked with me for 50
years i trust him completely
actually when we first met he thought i
was a vampire and he tried to stake me
through the heart i've apologized so
many times not quite enough times very
close though i'll let you know oh i have
to get ready for the next scene come to
my tent we'll talk there you can you
guys are going to love the next thing i
come in on a wire because you know i
can't fly wait are we getting back
together we need to talk the deviants
are back
we don't know how many there are
you need to come with us
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts and estevians are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
[Applause]
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
[Music]
you